today's topic i had the opportunity to
collaborate with sniko when i was in new
york
a couple months back and so me and him
had a long discussion there's a part of
the video that i wanted to show you
preach
and something unique happened to me
a couple days ago that i'm still
processing and it's like
it was they had me thinking like who do
i call
you know i can't call the police i can't
you know i don't
so i'm in my apartment i've just done
all these protests and then i come
come back and i'm with my girlfriend and
we're both naked in my
apartment i see someone across on the
neighboring building
taking pictures with the flash on it's 2
a.m both high
and i see him and like my girlfriend
says look she's taking pictures i don't
believe her
peek out the window yeah i see it for
sure he's taking pictures and i've
talked to this guy before i
trusted him but i noted when i was
talking to him and i mentioned my
youtube channel like
the different he had a different
reaction to other people it was like i
could feel like he was plotting
yeah like it was he wasn't asking out of
genuine interest
like what does he have you know
and so when he's taking pictures of me
it made me feel like
i was getting robbed because he knows
who i am he knows these pictures
could be valuable i don't know if he has
them if they were even good quality but
he could maybe sell them he could maybe
expose me
and so i felt like i was getting robbed
and i made a mistake and i threw
an egg at him he his window was across
and i threw a couple eggs and it landed
his apartment
big mistake i didn't i didn't process
like
i i lived in harlem i didn't you know i
didn't
think that maybe he has a gun none of
that crossed my mind but maybe he does
and he started yelling from the window
like i'm gonna [ __ ] you up next time i'm
gonna see you i'm a [ __ ]
up you're never safe here and like i
don't want to live there anymore
i don't want to live with you know my
head on a swivel i don't want to have to
to worry about my neighbors taking
pictures i don't want to feel unsafe and
he threw a bottle
and broke my window at 2 am chuck i
don't know if he was drunk but
this [ __ ] was broken and i couldn't stay
in my apartment that night and it's like
who do i call go ahead say ghostbusters
this man's out here bearing his heart
out and you out here 90s jokes
so it does raise an interesting question
right
if i call the police the neighborhood's
gonna think i'm a snitch
you know he's from there so he has more
authority in that neighborhood
bro like if i call obese everybody
thinks i'm a snitch and
you know what problems i can so if i
if i call somebody else like then now
i'm a criminal
you know if i call someone else to help
me out like if someone i don't have a
gun or anything
this is a tough thing as a man we have
we have a certain sense of pride and i
think some of it's very much justified i
think as you get older
you recognize what's at risk i can't
afford a criminal record i can't afford
to be in jail for a long period of time
i have people i have to provide for i
have responsibilities after me
and while my pride is important i
question all the time whether it's more
important than my mom being able
to get taken care of and so i've had
i was a violent person when i was a
teenager but i recognized the
consequences of that potentially long
term if i kept going that way which is
why i haven't fought for
for so many years but i've been in
situations where i've been close
and i've walked away and i've heard
people say like man that's a cowardly
move
well i might
you view it that way but i think the
measurement of the man is how he's able
to take care of the people around him
and what kind of man can't be there to
take care of his family when they're
most in need
that's how i view it what's the upside
of you beating that person up you
maintain your pride great
but then when you're people are
struggling because you can't be there to
provide
are you also being a man
i have responsibilities and it's tough
to say this to people
but i say this all the time your pride
is not nearly as important as you think
it is
like the amount of people that die over
ego
is absurd oh [ __ ] you stepped on my
shoes i'm
bravo you bumped into me apologize and
he doesn't apologize now you're fighting
somebody gets stabbed i've seen that
i've seen that too many times
i've seen that two minutes because
people couldn't swallow pride
guys life is meant to be lived don't be
out there throwing your life away over
petty bullsh
and now this is not necessarily petty
somebody threatened his home his abode
but what recourse does he have so when
he chooses to leave that home and he
doesn't engage that other person
someone's like yo you're a coward
that's not the way i view it he's making
the difficult choice
he's he's not giving into his ego and
fighting that person
because what's if he goes fighting
what's going to happen the person may
have a gun a knife
he might be stronger beat him up who
knows sneaker might win
go to jail but then he can't be there
for his girls
it wins in the fight then the other
person can sue yeah 100 percent he's in
the states
so you you know yeah y'all stay people
they you sue for nothing
for anything so one thing that i had to
learn growing up as a man
is to swallow my pride
all right let go of stuff walk away
walk away learn to do it it's
rarely worth it the amount of people who
have gone to jail
over spur of the moment fights is absurd
it's taken away so many of our young men
off these streets over [ __ ]
some dude says i'm on facebook i'ma
shoot him that happens happens very
often
too often it's dumb it's crazy
so that's why i want and you know nobody
disrespected me
he disrespected me yeah you can't
disrespect
you can't you you can't you know yo yo
yeah now we both going to jail let's go
be hard [ __ ]
let's go yeah i'm curious preach what do
you think about that
i removed everything off my car about
a couple of months ago because that
people just couldn't
recognize me and you know sometimes
there's a lot of there's a lot of people
that have road rage and stuff like that
to get out their car they you know
i don't i deal badly with that but at
the point where i'm at
i have to deal with that now i know
for a fact that i'm gonna have to work
extra hard the minute i'm gonna get kids
that's gonna be that's gonna be very
hard i become
very protective like i'm not a jealous
dude
my girl can handle herself on that if
she looks at me she's like
the kid is full then it's a different
thing but that's never happened
and it will like she can handle herself
but if she feels threatened
that that's a whole other thing you know
the whole thing where you know women get
pregnant and they got that big belly
and random strangers come up to them and
touch the belly
you're not down for that come on b
don't don't don't i just want to feel
the baby brian stiller whatever his name
is brian
don't you know that guy no that's a
singer whatever it doesn't mean
y'all know um no i don't i don't i don't
feel that sorry
oh i'm walking down this street and i
got it and you take pictures of my kids
i'm not mad at it not matter but what do
you do in those circumstances
oh man you know what i'm saying there's
the impulse i understand i think we all
get it if somebody threatens you
to fight back makes a lot of sense in
those situations somebody's taking a
picture of your kids the
instinct to fight back but is it the
smart choice is it not the right choice
no it's not
it's not okay and i understand when he
says you know
who do i call i know when i get it i
joked about it but i
get it because you call the police they
can't do nothing because it was not
really a threat
and you got this lurker doing whatever
the hell you want there's nothing for
people like that it's like well you know
you're known people are gonna take
pictures of you it's no big deal it's a
picture calm down
like they're gonna get it's like the
police they're good with that
it has to go to an extreme for something
to happen
for them to do something again i wasn't
i was in a bar with two of my
girlfriends i was at a bar
and one of my girls she goes to the
bathroom she goes to the bathroom before
i'm like okay go to the bathroom i'm
gonna order you
your drink i owed a drink there was
another dude this next dude is there and
he
starts talking to us which is fine but
at some point
he becomes intoxicated like that i think
the pelican kid or whatever what not
we get our drink me and my other friend
we
looked inside the drink i was like yo is
that a bug in the drink
and while we're looking because we
thought it was a bug and a drink
this dude throws something in there
in her faces like
right there and i'm like yo what the
hell is this like well you know just to
have a little bit of fun
so me i flipped i was about to i was
about to erase that dude
i tell the manager get rid of this dude
he gets rid of i go to the police
and they're like well you know
technically nothing happened
she would have had to ingest the drugs
or i would have to
you know what i mean i don't think it's
i don't think you're even then just to
find beating him up
no no you're not you are not because
then what you have to do is call the
cops but then the cops are going to tell
you
well you know we don't know what was in
there and then in the court it's not
going to hold and stuff like that so
what do you do
yeah nah but you know sneaker like him
being a young man and him thinking about
this logically is impressive to me
because i'll be honest with you at 21
2122 i did not
have nearly the restraint he did i would
have i would have been over
yeah knock knock who's there boom bam
blam blam sham shan yeah
bowling you know so it's just one of
those things
young man i'm telling you you're going
to be in those situations where someone
will disrespect you
walking away here's what i tell you
there's no
like immediate benefit you feel from
walking away in fact you're probably
going to feel
damaged you're gonna think that your ego
is gonna be buzzing at you
but the upside exists in all the
downsides you don't have to live through
the upside exists in you not having to
go to jail the upside exists you not
having to be killed
the upside exists between you not
getting beat up by the person
the upside exists from users not having
to deal with the negative
like the the risk to reward factor
look at it what are the risks if i
engage in this fight
are they mostly negative what's the
reward i maintain my pride
uh excuse me do you feel like the risk
and the reward are equal of course not
so at some point you gotta understand
when to walk away now that doesn't mean
that you don't have points where you
have to fight for your values
but also be smart yeah you have to value
values
that's right that's right honestly doing
that is
low-key noble is that what we're doing
now
we're gonna bring everything back let's
go bring it back who you go to sexy
all right so i just wanted to kind of
drop this video for you guys
um if you guys aren't aware go check out
sneko he's a young youtuber who's doing
great things
good and he great great content
especially geared towards young folks so
go check them out
uh but yeah that's pretty much all i
have with jenny thoughts on pride or nah
man that's pretty much
you nailed it so uh yeah leave a comment
below we wanna hear your thoughts
[Music]
me